ever get to the end of the film turn to
your buddy and say what the hell did we
just watch in fact never play this again
well wonder no more gentle moviegoer
we're here to give you the scoop on the
real meanings behind these complicated
movie endings
The Matrix Revolutions our hero in the
Matrix franchise neo was the only one
with enough power to break the matrix
and save humanity he spent the first two
films on an apparent collision course
with a near invincible artificial
intelligence program known as Agent
Smith but when their cataclysmic fight
in the third installment finally arrived
neo gave up so what happened at the end
of the Matrix Revolutions neo lies on
the brink of defeat until he realizes he
doesn't need to beat Smith at all
neo assimilates into the system and
Smith has wiped out while the matrix
reboots say what the dedicated fans of
The Matrix 101 picked apart the scene to
figure out what really went down and
here's what they discovered neo brokered
a sort of truce with the machines
allowing the continued existence of the
matrix free zone known as Zion while
healing the corruption in the program
personified by Smith the machines also
brant every human the chance to be
unplugged from the matrix and live in
the real world or to remain living in
their artificial reality the essay
concludes in a hopeful note this is a
world where eradication of the enemy is
seen for what it is a symptom of the
problem not a solution this is a world
where the creator and its creation have
the potential to live fruitfully in
peace and cooperation the fountain
Darren Aronofsky's the fountain features
three interlocking stories each set
hundreds of years apart all about a
couple coming to terms with death and
culminates in a wild weird ending in one
timeline a doctor works to cure the
brain tumor of his wife Izzie he's
written a book in which a Spanish
conquistador searches for the Tree of
Life for his queen meanwhile in the
future a cosmonaut heads for a distant
nebula and a biosphere containing the
tree interacting with Izzie spirit along
the way it all ends in the cosmonauts
fiery death the trees rebirth and an
ending in which is he spirit hands Tom
fruit from the tree which he plants in
her grave yep it's all deeply symbolic
and anyone hoping for a literal
explanation out of the fountain will be
somewhat frustrated Aronofsky himself
told The Washington Post
it's a Rubik's Cube of a story that's
all
really about coming to grips with our
own mortality he elaborated further in
the interview with a Nakul news it's a
film that's a journey and it's a trip
and it's an experience through the
meditation of a lot of these questions
there are ideas in there that I believe
but I think I wanted to leave it open so
that anyone can bring their own beliefs
to the table and that it could awaken
them and people can have a conversation
so there you have it your own
interpretation is the right one
apparently interstellar christopher
nolan sci fi f ik interstellar is pretty
cool but it's also pretty confusing
particularly in its final act astronaut
joseph Cooper on a desperate mission to
find a new home for Humanity plummets
into a black hole and drifts beyond the
event horizon finding himself inside a
tesseract there he can see inside his
daughter's bedroom any point in her life
he communicates with her through gravity
and Morse code guiding her to unlock the
equation that helps humanity escape
earth by the end Cooper is discovered
floating through space by later members
of the human race he saved watt to meet
his dying daughter whose AIDS at normal
speed while he's been on his
intergalactic travels and is thus much
older than he is huh
boy what it does and it feels like you
they could put a blindfold on you and
put you in a spaceship and take you to
Neptune and you could hop off on the
planet and they better have the sprocket
roll the whole film rests on the notion
the time is a circle and future humans
have the ability to travel within it
well they only get there by creating
this tesseract and helping past people
namely Cooper and his daughter Murph
finish their work it's a total chicken
or the egg style paradox but just go
with it and while Cooper was off
traveling through the wormholes little
Murphy was living on the surface of the
circle and kicking his whole journey
into gear from a science level until her
dad came back to it like he promised the
babadook figuring out the babadook isn't
that difficult provided you keep up with
a sudden change in perspective the
movies final act much of this indie
horror hit looks and feels like a
supernatural home invasion picture with
the creepy babadook creature tormenting
a single mother and her six-year-old son
but there's more going on beneath the
surface in the film's closing scenes the
babadook has possessed the mom and she
tries to strangle her son but the boy
draws the monster out of her with a
tender expression of love and a knife to
the lack of course
you don't love me the mother don't wanna
let me but I'm lucky mom the boys plan
works and the mom sends the babadook
fleeing to the basement where mom has
stored all mementos of her husband since
his death that's when we realized the
creature wasn't supernatural at all it
was her years of repressed grief which
had grown so powerful and threatened to
destroy the lives of everything it
touched in a perfect blend of
heartwarming and gross the babadook
closing moments show mother and son
gathering a bowl of worms which he takes
into the basement to feed the vanquished
beast she'll always carry the monster
with her because after all you can't get
rid of the babadook it follows in david
robert michels film it follows a girl
named Jay has a seemingly ordinary
hookup but soon after she's horrified to
realize she's been infected with a
sexually transmitted ghost who are you
gonna call someone else
the ghost takes various human forms
ranging from people in the victims
memories or creepy naked strangers that
only someone affected with the disease
can see it constantly walks in the
direction of the latest person infected
until it grabs them and kills them then
the ghost starts walking in the
direction of the previous person
infected and continues back down the
line your only option is to pass it off
to someone else hoping the chain keeps
going so that the ghost never gets to
you if that sounds ridiculous well it
kind of is but it's the setup for a
pretty devilish little film Jay learns
she can only escape the evil spirit
that's trying to kill her by sleeping
with someone else to pass it on
ultimately she and her friends try
killing it with generally unpleasant and
ambiguous results after the climactic
battle Jay and her friend Paul had sex
and later Paul seen driving past a group
of prostitutes in the film's final shot
the duo walked down a street while
someone or something follows behind much
of it follows is open to interpretation
and that's exactly what Mitchell wanted
as he said in multiple interviews he was
originally inspired by a nightmare which
he knew he was being followed knew he
couldn't get away and knew no one could
help him as for the ambiguity of that
last shot totally intentional Mitchell
wanted viewers to decide whether it was
still following Jay and her pals or not
sleep tight kids 2001 a Space Odyssey
there are no shortage of theories about
what exactly was going on in Stanley
Kubrick's 1960
sci-fi classic 2001 a Space Odyssey
rather than dive too far down that
rabbit hole let's instead offer
Kubrick's own assessment at the end in
which astronaut Dave Bowman comes into
contact with an extraterrestrial
monolith and goes through a bizarre
succession of experiences vast space
travel seeing himself at different ages
and finally being transformed into a
floating space fetus Kubrick explained
in an interview in a timeless state his
life passes from middle age to
senescence to death he is reborn and
enhanced being a star child an angel a
Superman if you like and returns to
earth prepared for the next leap forward
of man's evolutionary destiny this is
what happens in the film's simplest
level but what about the levels that
aren't so simple
Kubrick pointed out the 2001 concerns
itself with elements of philosophy and
metaphysics that have nothing to do with
the bear plotline so whatever his
summary tells you about Bowman's fate
you can trust there's more to it and
that any extra meaning is entirely up to
you I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
Kubrick's explanation continued the film
becomes anything the viewer sees in it
if the film stirs the emotions and
penetrates the subconscious of the
viewer if it stimulates however inchoate
Lee is mythology and religious yearnings
and impulses that it has succeeded got
all that great just meet us down at the
bar once you've done stimulating your
mythological and religious yearnings and
impulses or whatever
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos at
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which endings you
think should have been on the list